from John and Chrissy to a One Direction
singer et is on 2016 baby watch she
likes to eat and you know we have a
little baby that you for two I think she
liked sweets a little more than she used
to John Legend dish song Chrissy Teigen
pregnancy cravings in November a month
after they announced they were expecting
a couple of posted this adorable snap
John simply wrote quote we're pregnant
this will be the couple's first child
together and we can expect him or her
this spring in October Kelly Clarkson
confirmed she's having a boy when she
shared this cute pic of daughter River
rose but the 33 year olds had many
believing that she and husband Brandon
Blackstock were maybe having twins when
she called in to Leeanne and Courtney
Kerr uncorked
I'm gonna be everywhere once I get these
kids puffed out and done did Kelly
Clarkson just tell us she's having twins
but Kelly's rep told eg it's not true
can we talk about how there are a lot of
musical babies coming into the world
next year
Louie Tomlinson is going to be a
first-time dad in early 2016 the One
Direction singer's baby news came as a
bit of a surprise this past July
la-based stylist Briana jungwirth is the
mom Carter and wife Lauren kit shared
their baby news and had a gender-reveal
on Dancing with the Stars right here
guys
next Ben McKenzie and Morena Baccarin
Ben's rep confirmed e.t Eve at the
Gotham co-stars turned a real-life
couple
we're expecting back in September it'll
be his first child and marine a second
and speaking of co-stars once upon a
time with Jennifer Goodwin and Josh
Dallas are going to be parents for a
second time Jamie Dornan and his wife
Amelia Warner will also be welcoming
baby number two in 2016 I write you guys
a which celeb baby are you most excited
to meet in 2016
let me know over on Twitter and have a
Happy New Year
you